[Music]
thanks it's always nice to get an
Applause even before the uh presentation
always uh feels good so yeah really nice
to see so many faces here uh in this
room uh for everyone to learn together
with me about data set enrichment using
l LMS uh so you you can actually see it
says 27th well it is of course the 30th
of November uh and I hope still everyone
has enough attention left right before
the lunch uh so that's for me the
challenge to uh yeah bring it in a nice
way so what about me I'm Yun overi I'm a
machine learning engineer at cbia data
and what we do is we go to companies and
we help the companies uh bring their
machine learning products into
production
and also make sure that they stay into
production so that is what we do uh as a
company and as a DAT day I work as a
machine learning engineer sometimes as a
data
scientist so you all here um to learn
also about uh llms and llms are booming
so many people talk about it these days
and you hear so many things about it uh
yeah also in the
news and so why is that well we can see
uh C GPT got
launched it took CET GPT only 5 days to
acquire a million
users and that is really really super
fast because if we compare to some other
services like Instagram and Spotify
Instagram took 75 days Spotify took 150
days then we can really see that is
quite quite
fast so these are are also really big
services and still jgpt it it got uh
really big in a really short
time so yeah clearly something is going
on
here so what can all these LMS do so we
have a couple use cases here for example
you can do search there's quite a battle
now in the search space where big
companies are competing with each other
to implement llms also in their search
engines you could also do summarization
really compress a large text get the
keys uh features out of there uh to
create a shorter text or for example
text generation also useful for maybe
people in high school and then uh they
can generate a an essay for them uh that
yet you can also do or classification
for example sentiment analysis hey what
is uh the tone of voice or the main
emotion in this text you can also do
that
but I want today focus on information
extraction so what does that mean say on
the left hand side we have a text given
the text that follows extract properties
XYZ that is something we could ask the
llm which is the parrot here in the
middle because it's very
talkative and then using the llm we can
on the right hand side get some
structured data
back so what is this structure data well
yl Json CV anything that has a
predictable structure to it and then we
could ask the llm okay maybe we can grab
that information right from the
text so what do this document for
example look like well here for example
I have a house listing this is a house
in Amsterdam that's being advertised and
it has some properties here like a price
and uh yeah the square uh amount of
meters uh and also a description and
that comes from yeah a house listing
website this is really popular one in
the nland where we have all these houses
that are being listed and people use
this frequently to you to to find their
new
home but so actually if we zoom in on
this description uh there's a really
large piece of text but what is inside
this description uh we can see okay it
says here there's a parking possibility
there's an elevator
there's a balcony facing Southwest uh
pets are not allowed sharing not allowed
students not allowed smoking is not
allowed and all these things when you're
searching for a new home that is
potentially very valuable information to
have but yeah it's hidden inside this
large piece of text so we cannot really
use it to to filter and then yeah you
are searching for your home and you
really have to go inside the text to see
ah I'm a student but this home is not
for
me so then I can really uh read your
mind and I can already hear you thinking
can we extract these properties using a
large language
model and so that is indeed uh what
we're going to take a look a look at uh
can we use these housing descriptions uh
and together with an LM to extract some
uh useful
properties all right so let's uh start
with doing some prompts with the
llm and we're going to start with a
quite naive approach uh to then later
get to more sophisticated
approaches and there I want to say a
naive approach and sophisticated
approach it doesn't necessarily mean
it's a Well performing approach or non
well performing approach they're just
naive and simple and
sophisticated so that uh we're going to
take a look
at all right so let's start with a
simple prompt here on the left hand side
can you guys see it here also
great so this prompt here we for example
saying okay uh a house listing will
follow as it appeared on a housing
website please extract the following
information from the listing is press
pet friendly yes no or
unknown and then here uh we're using a
bit of formatting this is similar yeah
to markdown so the llm uh it comes
familiar to the llm and here we have
this variable house so what is that that
is actually this entire house
description uh that we just saw so we
just copy pasted right into there with
all these yeah different things that
it's saying uh were not allowed or allow
uh so we paste it in there so what does
the LM output uh no it's not PR friendly
okay well simple uh uh simple trial uh
let's make it a bit uh uh yeah more more
sophisticated so here we can also ask
okay same thing but provide us a quote
so we get a bit more confidence in the
output of this llm does does it make
sense can we indeed find it back in the
original text uh and indeed here it can
say yeah that's not allowed it's stated
there literally in the text okay that's
nice now okay let's see if we add a
couple more properties so a garden
parking place uh is suitable for couple
so that would be a little bit harder
property to extract so it has a bit more
reason okay when is an apartment
suitable for a couple uh well then is
there enough space or that LS to think a
bit so we can also try that uh and does
it have a
balcony and so here indeed yeah you see
it uh it gives some nice answers about
that uh and
oops uh but then it's still yeah the
usefulness for this is really limited so
we don't have structure it's not a
predictable structure here it's just a
bit markdown formatting so we want a
structure so then uh let's see how do we
get this structure how do we get the llm
to Output a structure for
us so now we're doing the same thing
here where it's the dots that is
actually us stating which properties to
extract which is the garden and the
parking place and so forth and here we
are asking the llm kindly pre provide
the output in a Json object uh and
indeed okay we get a Json object okay so
that that is
nice that is something we can uh we can
finally work with when we're starting
using uh python to yeah use these
properties uh but maybe we can actually
bring back this quote so previously here
we just get the values maybe we want a
quote uh and actually here what we can
do we can just spell out an entire uh
example Json response and then uh where
wherever we putting dots we want the llm
to fill in the
dots so indeed oh cool uh you can see
the llm it's filled in basically the the
blanks and also quote now is back uh
that that is cool uh but if it doesn't
Find a quotes now just outputting a dash
so yeah we have to par the dash that's
not very
predictable um we're going to work with
that later so now this this Json object
that's nice so we can put it actually uh
in a json. loads uh python
function so that is
nice but what if I change actually the
input of this uh this house so
previously we had a nicely formatted
description of a house but now for
example we have a description of a house
it's super minimal almost no information
for for some reason the the real estate
agent they didn't fill in this
description and then what what is then
the LM prone for if you give it way too
little information it is then prone to
hallucinate so here actually we we just
ask it okay extract these
properties from from this housing text
but there is no housing text and just it
completely makes up just a house on its
own so it's saying okay this is a
beautiful modern house it's located in
123 Main Street any Town USA just
completely non-existent Street and then
yeah it's it cost half a
million and that is just uh
nonsense but even the worst part is is
this really this is our output is this
string here at the top so for some
reason I just didn't have the all the
information that needed and even just
put the bit the string at the top and
that is really problematic because it's
no longer a valid Json object we canot
even par
anymore so then here okay what what can
we do now there's a couple ways a bit to
to mitigate this so yeah this can happen
so if you if you're using this really on
a large scale and then yeah there are
going to be examples like
this so either if your llm you have a
temperature set to to f value higher
than zero maybe you can just run it
again okay see if does it provide
different output or maybe even we have
this nice error here where actually yeah
it's describing okay why cannot it parse
the Json error we can also prompt the LM
again and just show it uh it's its own
produced error so basically okay you
just produce this for me and just show
it back to the LM okay try again this is
this is the error that I got maybe it
can do better the next
time all right so let's go back to this
uh working
example
uh and then actually uh next question
pops up if we're going to do this this
for many houses and then we can see okay
uh all these values does it have a u a
garden or a parking place uh if we're
going to do this for more houses and if
we want to be able to trust whatever the
llm is generating and we also want to do
some type of elev evaluation because
otherwise we're just um uh completely
blind trusting whatever the LM produces
and we want to be able to a bit check
okay how well is this llm in extracting
all these properties for
us so here we can say okay once we have
once we are inside the python world so
we just pared the Json maybe we can
compare compare this output with uh some
ground
truth so how does that look like uh a
very simple approach not even
considering the quotes is really just to
compare these values uh and then we can
see okay how many of these properties
did it correctly extract well in this
this case it got 60% right and that is
taking into account both the actual uh
value does it have a garden yes or no uh
or did it did it appear in the text so
that is also what we're checking did the
llm think it was in the text at all if
it's not in the text then uh doesn't
have need to know uh the the
value all right and so with that uh if
we run it
uh enough times for some houses we can
actually do a bit Benchmark so that is
interesting so here we we're doing
exactly the same thing a bit the same
prompt uh for for some number of houses
uh for GPT 3.5 and palm
two and yeah that's nice okay so if we
are indeed we want to solve this use
case and then we can get an idea okay
which llm uh works well with this prompt
and which llm can extract this
information in a good way uh so that is
quite useful that we can do a benchmark
like
this but for those who are really
carefully looking at the slides you can
see in the legend It also says gp4 but
it's not here where is
gp4 well gp4 actually uh we tried this
and then it got 100% uh incorrect so
we're running this Benchmark like yeah
what is
happening and yeah we're using ml flow
and then tracking it a bit and and then
uh yeah we can see okay these succeeded
and then here is gp4 and everything
filled so that was weird so we were like
okay investigating a bit in mlflow we we
look a bit okay we use this prompt this
is the
output so what happened uh it turned out
the gp4 it was really talkative so it
really liked uh to to get get the proper
conversation so it it even though we
just asked for only Jason it's still uh
providing a bit of text at the top and
the bottom yeah really only just need
this
one so yeah to mitigate that either we
we do a bit Rejects and we extract this
uh or we can just ask hey gp4 return
nothing else except a valid Jon object
do not surround the Jon object with back
Tex or any other
text so really these this is really
where the the prompt becomes important
only these small notices makes the makes
the the LM act differently
your
microphone did you really have to use a
follow-up
prompt uh like another one you mean yeah
couldn't couldn't you put this in the
first prompt yeah it was uh just
rerunning the entire thing with uh with
prompt we don't really uh run like a
second prompt with the information of
the of the first it just yeah rerunning
with a different prompt alt together
yeah
yeah good question
thanks all right so indeed now we get
gp4 in the Benchmark as well so it's a
bit in the middle here so that is
cool but actually can we do better so
now we just went the route of uh giving
the llm an example of this Json scheme
and then putting in some dots and then
saying okay fill this in for us with
other other other ways to do
this so
let's see okay this um this is the Jason
example but maybe uh we can do something
else uh maybe we can actually Define
some penic
model and then maybe we can print out a
really elaborate scheme of what we want
to
extract so say for example we have this
pantic model and actually we can
instruct pantic okay print out your
entire scheme in a Json object so here
on the right hand side you can see it's
quite big but it's really containing
many kind of elaborate details so this
property it it has to be of type either
a string or a null this has to be a
boine or a null and then really all the
the intricate details are listed there
in in the
scheme and yeah pantic schemes they
should come familiar to the llm because
then it has knowledge about uh all these
things that that exist so maybe it can
work nicely together with a pen
model so let's try that so here we uh we
have the same prompt but then here we're
uh putting in this this template which
is uh yeah our poentic scheme and then
again the house listing let's see what
does it
return okay quite uh quite nicely we get
again adjacent
object and then really the the
additional Advantage here is then we
have defined this pantic model uh which
we had defined a scheme for it should
output the Json which is compatible with
this pantic scheme so now we can also
load it back into our pantic
model so that is pretty nice so we can
go like right back into into the python
world without this json. loads like we
can be uh more confident if if that
function succeeds indeed uh we get the
right structure
back so that is useful but what is the
performance so that is yeah in the end
what uh what
matters and here we can see okay GPT 3.5
is doing slightly better GPT 4 okay also
and palm it actually does worse so this
is really where you can see okay all
these llms they they were trained in
really different R are completely
different
models and yeah providing really this
this very detailed amount of information
in the scheme it doesn't per se mean
okay it's going to perform better it it
really differs per
model
and you can now see okay on the right
hand side and we have some space
left so can we do even better than
this so let's take a look at that
so this is uh specific to open AI which
is called function calling so what does
function calling
do function calling it was quite
recently introduced so June of this year
and what function calling aims to do is
to create a nice Gateway for you to
execute functions uh after getting the
result from the llm so a typical use
case for example would be uh exposing
some functions to the llm maybe get the
current weather uh or yeah do some
Google search and then the llm can
choose for itself okay I want to call
this function because I require this
information uh and then you can call the
function for the LM because that is
something the LM itself cannot do and
then you put it back uh in the chat
again
but maybe we can also use this same
functionality this function calling but
then to extract actually these
properties from a
text so let's see about that so now we
get a bit more specific into the
code so here we are starting a new chat
completion with a GPT
3.5 where we here actually listing okay
these are the functions that you have
available you could call these functions
if you want
and this functions object is really a
list with a really specific scheme of
okay how does this function look like
really okay these are the parameters in
the function and they should be of these
types this is the description of these
parameters and in that way uh the llm is
aware of of the function that you made
available for it and then uh it could
call it even we're actually here
defining a function call which is
forcing it to call this
function so that is useful functionality
for us because we just care about
extracting really this this structured
information okay so let's uh let's try
that so now um because actually
we are forc calling this function
everything that LM does it has to go
yeah through this function like its
output has to be a format where it's
calling this function so the only thing
that that that we've uh need in the
prompt is actually the house the house
text so we just put the house text there
and as a context we can actually
slightly change the context we can
actually point it a bit more towards its
task which is that it's an assistant is
a large language model designed to
extract structured data from
text okay so let's see what happens
so again we have this chat completion
here and then as an output it's saying
okay I want to call this function with
these values so the the values that it's
going to call the function with is sprad
friendly has Garden has parking place
and that is exactly the information that
we desired to
extract so that is nice and now again
yeah we can uh load that Json object
yeah in a python dictionary and then we
can call this
function that is really nice so we have
now a really yeah strict interface that
it has to go through this through this
function uh and the llm is yeah
fine-tuned for for calling these
functions as
well and even the last part where what
what we're doing uh was actually yeah
loading in this Json object and then
calling this function uh there's even a
library for you uh I would say it's a
bit
extra juice if you're really getting
into this it makes your life just a
little bit easier uh and what it does is
you can actually again instead of
defining that really large Json file
describing the function you can again uh
Define a a class uh where you're
actually defining also the properties
that you want to
extract and then yeah you can print the
schema that we before we had to generate
this entire schema ourselves now you can
uh yeah generate that schema from from
that class that is pretty nice and there
yeah we are uh now doing the same uh
chat completion uh and then yeah we can
to together with this Library we can uh
extract these
properties so that is uh a useful
shortcut if you're really doing this uh
yeah in uh more more times and then you
can use the shortcut the library yeah it
comes in
useful and then again yeah we can go
into pyth world uh it will again be this
this object uh called House
features so that is nice but how does it
perform again function calling and this
is where it gets a bit odd so yeah we
got really enthusiastic about all this
this functionality and we can really
force it inside this function uh but we
can see gp4 is performing around the
same as before and GPT 3.5 yeah it's
performing even a little bit less
well so this is really where we're
coming back uh to the point that yeah we
have this bit naive approach just
provide like this entire Json example
and then we provide a schema and then
even a function interface that it has to
go through uh yeah here we can really
see okay it depends per model it depends
how you design your prompt it really
makes sense uh to try out different
things if you really want yeah a
performance use C out of
this all right so now what yeah we saw
all these three different methods so uh
yeah what did we actually do so let's uh
conclude a little bit so yeah this was
cool because we have this data set where
we're for example uh listing a house
yeah we can add some new properties to
it uh which we extracted using the llm
uh does it have a balcony is it pet
friendly that could be potentially very
useful if you have data sets lying
around with all that information that is
currently hidden uh extracting it and
then yeah working with it uh uh because
it's structured data we can uh filter it
you can all do all these operations that
you previously couldn't
do so we saw three meth methods
providing ajacent example uh providing a
prentic schema and even using open AI
API uh which is function calling to to
extracted information with yeah varying
performances so if we conclude using
llms for data set enrichment it is good
if you provide uh explicit
instructions so remember where the llm
it started surrounding the Json with its
own text yeah you have to be really
explicit and instruct the LM exactly
what it should
do the output form is explicit so you're
going to ask it to provide me in ad Json
uh in this format and that is what I
want as an
output the input data is comprehensive
so if your house descriptions if they're
super short uh then yeah the llm has
little data to work with it might start
hallucinating that's not
nice and also if the data is valuable
enough to justify cost so these are
really powerful models uh so you have to
ask yourself the question okay uh is the
data indeed yeah of a certain complexity
that I need an LM to extract it can I
not can I not use a simpler method so
okay if that is indeed uh the answer is
yes then uh you can weigh the cost
against the the the benefit so yeah
these properties if they're valuable to
you you want to use them later then
indeed maybe it can be a very good
option for
you do also exploit uh structured output
possibilities so yeah Json pantic they
can really help uh designing your prompt
getting that information out of there uh
and also function calling if you are
using uh
GPT and in that case the llm it loves uh
the house searching uh world so that is
that is good uh and then also I'm quite
curious what is your use case so you
listen to all of this maybe in your mind
you're already thinking a bit about what
is shown on the on the on the on the TV
and then also ah okay maybe how can I
use this I'm also curious about it so
yeah if you have an idea and then come
and tell me afterwards that would be
nice uh and then for now I would really
like to thank
everyone there is some time for
questions uh yes thanks first of all for
the very interesting talk um I was
wondering about the cost of these like
for example here you had 100 samples for
each test I
think what does it cost to shoot 100
samples do you know I didn't uh measure
it uh but the cost for this was still
relatively low uh we really uh yeah
focused on creating a nice experiment
seeing what works well and what not so
we didn't run it through the full data
set yet because yeah our full data set
is really uh yeah the like the pararius
housing website the data set is like
thousands of of
houses uh so there it's really
interesting question also for us to to
explore yeah but it's relatively low
like some 100 EUR or do you have any
yeah I mean depends on the company
what's relatively low cost exactly yeah
you're right inde yeah it's really below
100 so yeah it's yeah all right thank
you
yeah thanks uh I have a question if you
have any ideas how to clean up the data
set later bit because the Min score of
0.5 or
0.6 are there any quick things you can
do to even improve that without the llm
I don't know or like similarity
detection of the cows or something I'm
doing similar things with a doop ad data
set so just want to clean it up a bit
yeah okay so the cleaning before you
hand it to the LM no the outut from the
lmm so you can filter out bit of the
hallucinations and
stuff yeah all right yeah so in this
case these uh uh hallucinations like the
example that I showed it didn't parse at
all because it just provided this extra
string at the top and then yeah the the
output that it would generate if it
didn't uh if it did parse if it didn't
do this thing uh yeah there uh there you
would have to uh yeah do some do some
checks or maybe you can uh yeah already
be a bit care if your description is
super
short uh yeah in these samples we are
kind of aware which samples we were
putting in so we knew okay this one is a
one with super small description and the
other ones had the larger
description uh but yeah that that's
that's really why I'm also also yeah
stating okay do experiment and then
we're putting all these plots together
uh because yeah this is like generally
in in in AI a thing right can we trust
it and then especially with llms before
you start really using it okay do
explore around what works well what is
it
outputting
thanks uh so this is um uh a little bit
also the same question but can you tell
um uh in the prompt not to hallucinate
so can you say if there's no description
don't give me an answer or something
like that yeah yeah okay so what could
you put in the prompt such that you do
you want to get warned about when it's
it doesn't have enough information or
yeah I I I don't want false information
I mean 6 is okay if it's an enrichment
but if that means 40% is is totally made
up information I don't want it yeah yeah
yeah I yeah I think it's a good question
so uh I didn't try to fight the
hallucinations here yet I just observed
it but I have um some colleagues also
and they work on a use case where it's
also quite important can we trust the
output and then they're um yeah putting
something in the prompt which is saying
uh okay if you have too little
information just don't proceed at all
just you state that like in the output
that you didn't have enough information
and then you can a bit prevent okay uh
like it has a little information it's G
to just going to try its best to put
something there anyway but yeah you you
can uh you can uh put something smart in
the prompt and then you can also say
okay yeah this just doesn't work at all
yeah and did you try with a small uh
amount of information did chat GPT uh
four also uh hallucinate there or is it
just
3.5 um not not sure the example was I
think with 3.5
yeah thanks yeah thanks good
question one more
question
hey nice work um did you try it in
Dutch yeah okay that's a good question
that uh we provided it all English
text uh that is actually yeah it's it's
it's really one of the things we also
want to explore so different models
different proms also on different
languages because yeah these models are
known to perform differently on the yeah
different language Set uh so yeah the
short short answer is no we didn't try
with touch and the other answer is we
are really interested to do it uh yeah
so my experience is if you give it a a
nicely grammar text then it will be all
right in English but we we are in the
medical field and people don't write
nicely grammar grammarly correct and
then you get very strange
results but might for you use case it
might not be a problem yeah and what
would be a strange result like why is it
so strange it doesn't recognize it so it
does yeah yeah okay yeah yeah indeed I
we like really good suggestions here
some some that I already already thought
about and then the others yeah is good
to extend this experiment
[Music]
yeah